congress is an independent branch of
government you all know that we're
obviously monitoring her travel as we
always do for members of congress and
we've taken all appropriate measures to
ensure the safety of her travel
throughout the region
let me be clear
the speaker's visit is totally
consistent with our long-standing one
china policy
we've been very clear that nothing has
changed about our one china policy which
is guided of course by the taiwan
relations act three joint usprc
communiques and the six assurances
we've said that we oppose any unilateral
changes to the status quo from either
side
we said we do not support taiwan
independence
and we said as i said again yesterday
that we expect cross-strait
differences to be resolved by peaceful
means
now we have communicated this directly
to the prc at the highest levels
including in last week's call between
president biden and president xi
national security adviser secretaries of
state and defense the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff have also made
this very clear to beijing in a half a
dozen recent high-level conversations
now we've seen a number of announcements
from the prc in just the last several
hours
that are unfortunately
right in line with what we had
anticipated and what we talked about
yesterday
now there's no reason as i said
yesterday for beijing to turn this visit
uh which is consistent with
long-standing us policy into some sort
of crisis
or use it as a pretext to increase
aggressiveness uh and military activity
in or around
the taiwan strait
now
or beyond her travel
and again as i made clear yesterday
before the speaker's travel was
confirmed by her
china has positioned itself to take
further steps and we expect that they
will continue to react over a longer
term horizon i couldn't give you a date
certain of what that horizon looks like
but we certainly would expect them to
react even beyond her trip
including announcing additional
uh large-scale lives by fire exercises
of course they've already started doing
some of that today flying across the
median line seen press reports of them
doing that today
and using economic coercion
it's exactly in line with the playbook
that we anticipated and talked to you
about yesterday
the united states will not and does not
will not seek and does not want a crisis
we are prepared to manage what beijing
chooses to do
at the same time we will not engage in
saber rattling we will continue to
operate in the seas and the skies of the
western pacific as we have done for
decades
we will continue to support taiwan
defend a free and open indo-pacific and
seek to maintain communication with
beijing
we'll keep doing what we are doing which
is supporting cross-strait peace and
stability and then just real quick
lastly uh uh cream uh
hinted to this at the top uh the
president welcomes
today's announcement of an extension of
the truce in the yeming conflict the
truce in yemen of course was a key
agenda item during the president's visit
to saudi arabia where he met with the
king and the crown prince and with
leaders from across the region
we're grateful for the leadership of
saudi arabia throughout this truce
process as well as the sultan as well as
for the sultan and leaders
of oman who have also played an
important role throughout
this truce is now going on five months
has brought a period of unprecedented
calm in yemen saving thousands of lives
and bringing tangible relief for
countless yemenis five months which may
not sound like a lot but when you're
talking about seven years of war and
thousands and thousands of humanity
lives it counts for a lot and now we
have a chance to extend this another two
months
so we urge the yemeni parties to seize
this opportunity to work constructively
under un auspices to reach an inclusive
comprehensive agreement that paves the
way for adorable yemeni-led resolution
to the conflict
advancing the peace process is going to
require courage and dedication from all
sides
the united states will remain committed
and engaged in efforts to advance peace
in yemen and to bring relief to the
yemeni people and with that
take some questions
thank you
thank you john how concerned is the
administration right now that the
afghanistan has become a safe haven for
terrorists i think if you were to
asked some members of al qaeda asking
them how how safe they feel in
afghanistan right now
i think we proved
uh to a fairly well this weekend
that it isn't a safe haven and it isn't
going to be going forward
what will the repercussions be for uh
the taliban harboring ozwafri
i'm not going to telegraph uh moves and
decisions that we might make i'm
certainly not going to get ahead of
anything at this point i would just make
two points one uh
the strike itself shows how serious we
are
uh
about accountability shows how serious
we are about defending our interests
and we're going to maintain as i said at
the outset we're going to maintain this
over the horizon capability in fact i'd
go so far as to say we're going to
continue to try to improve that
capability going forward
and number two we've communicated very
directly with taliban leaders um
uh our views of of their willingness
at at some level of course
to to harbor
uh
zawahiri and and his family and we have
made it clear
that
not we believe not we think not we
suppose but we know
that that's a violation of the doha
agreement
so obviously john just to follow up on
that clearly this shows accountability
for zwahiri and for al qaeda wherever
they are as you got him in afghanistan
but it doesn't show accountability for
what the secretary of state described as
a gross violation of the doha agreement
so can you commit that there will be
some act to demonstrate that they will
be held accountable in some way and how
do you do that without it looking like
yeah we'll just take out one by one you
can keep allowing more again i'm not
going to telegraph punches that haven't
been thrown yet
or decisions that haven't been made yet
we're going to stay vigilant to the
threat we've made it clear to the
taliban
that that we know
what what they did and uh we know who
they harbored and we know some of the
steps they tried to take after the
strike to
to cover up the evidence of it um so
we're mindful of it um
but i'm not going to get ahead of
decisions policy decisions haven't been
made i mean
the
it's not that we take the taliban at
their work but just indulge me for a
second they claim they want a
relationship with the united states and
with the west they claim they want to
open up um and be part of the
international community they claim they
want financing that's exactly right
peter um so
if that's true if that's what they
really want uh then it would behoove
them to to pay close attention to what
we just did over the weekend um and to
meet their agreements
under the doha agreement without
identifying them how many other al-qaeda
individuals or leaders do you assess are
presently living in afghanistan i'm not
going to get into intelligence matters
uh peter we we said even before we left
afghanistan last august that we knew al
qaeda was uh was present in afghanistan
in relatively small numbers uh and
we know that there are still some
al-qaeda fighters in afghanistan i would
again without getting into uh classified
information here i would say the
number's not very large and that's how
and that's core al-qaeda there are also
offshoots like isis k which we know are
very active in afghanistan and um right
now the the other thing that i want to
say and i know rightly we're focused on
afghanistan but again i want to take you
back in time a little bit to about a
year ago when we talked about this
threat
and then our departure from afghanistan
we know that al qaeda has metastasized
both in terms of character now they've
got different offshoot groups al-shabab
isis and isis has got splinter groups of
its own but they've also metastasized
geographically they're not focused as
much in a presence in afghanistan
they're in north africa they're in this
the sahel they're throughout the middle
east and they're in yemen uh so i mean
there's
uh there are other
uh counterterrorism threats in other
parts of the world we're gonna stay
focused on them all i get i get that
we're focused on afghanistan right now
but we're not taking our eye off the
rest of the world either
john something you just said is not
consistent with what we were told last
year you're saying that you've always
known there was a small number of al
qaeda in afghanistan president biden
said what interest do we have in
afghanistan at this point with al qaeda
gone
yeah i mean
in a major way al qaeda was not playing
uh no wait let me let me finish they
weren't playing a major role uh in
in operations uh or resourcing or
planning in afghanistan but
peter i i know specifically because i
was at a different podium a year ago and
we talked about the fact that al qaeda
had a presence in afghanistan but small
and not incredibly powerful or or potent
and i think again without getting into
numbers we would still assess that to be
the case so we know that the taliban was
harboring
the world's most wanted terrorist
you guys gave a whole country to a bunch
of people that are on the fbi most
wanted list what did you think was going
to happen i would take issue with the
premise that we gave a whole country to
terrorist groups i mean again i'd i'd
i'd i'd encourage you to ask the world's
number one terrorist how is that not
giving a country to
a
a terrorist sympathizing group uh
if not
giving them permission to have
terrorists just
sit on a balcony the question i mean
peter the way you ask that it makes it
sound like we owned afghanistan a year
ago it wasn't our country um it was an
independent sovereign state and the
president made a bold decision to end a
war that had been going on for 20 years
because he believed
then and still believes now that our
national security interests are best met
by meeting the threats of today not the
threats of 2001 and
we've you know i don't want to
relitigate the whole war here but
obviously no one anticipated the ghani
government to fall as fast as it did um
but we said at the time
that as we depart afghanistan we're
gonna keep vigilant we're gonna stay
ready and we're not gonna let
afghanistan become a safe haven for
terrorists who threaten our homeland and
this past weekend we proved that case
precisely but so now that you know that
the taliban is not living up to the part
of the deal that they made with the u.s
do not let afghanistan be a place that
terrorists feel like they can be safe
what are you going to do about it well
that gets to peter's question i'm not
going to telegraph uh decisions that
haven't been made or
or or policy uh policy initiatives one
way or the other
i would just say for some spectacular
terrorist attack in the u.s
to then say oh well there's terrorists
if we want to say peter in afghanistan
now we can go get him if we were peter
then we wouldn't have taken the hit on
saturday the strike that we took on mr
zawahiri if we were just waiting this
isn't about waiting
it's about watching
and we watched very closely and we acted
on what we learned and i would go so far
as to say not only the american people
are safer as a result of president
biden's decision but the rest of the
world is safer does that mean that the
threat from al qaeda is over
no of course it's not now they'll have
to make some decisions here and we'll
watch that too
and if we discern a threat to the
american homeland again from them or any
other terrorist group the president will
reserve the right to take that action
again
thank you john now that uh house speaker
is actually in taiwan can you give us a
sense of president biden's thoughts on
the matter does he support that
and then secondly what kind of lines of
communication defending are ongoing uh
today between the two governments
uh well i mean you have the speaker of
the house it's in taipei uh right now of
course she's going to be meeting with
government leaders we have stayed in
touch with
our taiwan counterparts of course
and
and we've stayed in touch with speaker
pelosi's staff as she has progressed
through this
trip just to clarify i met with beijing
uh i don't have any
specific
conversations with the with the prc
leaders uh to speak to today uh but we
as you know we have an ambassador there
we have an embassy i mean we are in
routine uh communication with the
leaders in beijing but i refer you to
the state department for anything that
they might or might not have
communicated and then about president
biden
i've said i said this yesterday the the
president as a former senator
fully respects
the right and the prerogative
frankly the responsibility of members of
congress to include the speaker of the
house to travel overseas that's a
different question or that's a different
response and does he support her going
he respects the speaker's decision to
travel to taiwan
yeah courtney
thanks um i wanted to ask about ukraine
specifically the refugee situation uh
the president had committed to accepting
a hundred thousand refugees from ukraine
and i know that whole idea is that they
would stay here temporarily for two
years
is the expectation that um or is that
still the u.s view that they should be
here for two years or would you or would
the president consider extending that
given that the war is ongoing and you
don't know when people may or may not be
able to return home yeah i don't i don't
have any policy changes to speak to
today so uh i mean i can happily take
that question or refer to the state
department but i i don't know of any
changes to the
the essential decision by the president
to provide a place for ukrainian
refugees to come even if it is just
temporarily i mean what we've seen
over the course of uh
of now almost six months of war is that
a lot of ukrainians who left in the
early weeks
are going back
for various reasons
and
in the early weeks of the war
we were seeing
families cross the border and then
uh either the
the mom or the dad or or both would drop
the kids off with somebody and go right
back in so there's a strong desire by
ukrainians to be in their homeland to be
in their country and we respect that
you have to ask congress for the ability
for them to stay long i'm not gonna i
won't get ahead of policy decisions that
haven't been made yet i mean our
commitment to supporting ukraine has not
changed there's no change to the
president's commitment in this regard in
terms of welcoming refugees but i just
don't have any changes for you today
thank you
mr kirby as already killed he killed
more than 200 people in tanzania and in
kenya in 1998 and right now even though
the u.s compensated u.s citizens who
were victims of those bombings the
people in kenya and tanzania they've
received nothing what message do you
have for them
yeah i'd say the same thing i told mr
ducey here that uh that this is not just
a good day for the united states of
america it's a good day for the world
that the families of the victims of
those bombings were not compensated by
the u.s what message do you have i don't
have any compensation policies here to
speak to again
mr zawari's death is is good for
everybody around the world um he was a
killer and and uh
and it's uh it's a good thing that he's
no longer walking the face of the earth
it also means that we're going to have
to stay vigilant to this threat going
forward
wow
i got to take issue with that
i did not say that and i don't even know
where you came from on that one of
course all lives matter
i didn't say that i didn't say i i
didn't say that sir and i really really
take exception um to the to the the tone
and the implication in that question of
course their lives matter every life
matters particularly a life taken so
violently
as by the hands of a terrorist if those
lives didn't matter sir
we wouldn't have taken the action that
we took this weekend and if those lives
didn't matter sir we wouldn't be staying
vigilant to the threat going forward
which we will do
on taiwan
all the dancing
nancy squared
second
you saw today from china's response to
surprise i know that there were the
drills and missile tests that beijing
announced that they would conduct was
that what they've been warning about um
in private to the white house
i'm not going to talk about uh uh
private discussions uh what i would tell
you is that what we've seen thus far
and she just arrived uh is consistent
with the playbook that we expected them
to uh
to run
and we'll just keep watching it it's one
of the reasons why i came out here
yesterday to sort of lay some of that
out for you so what we've seen so far
been pretty consistent and is the
president planning to speak with speaker
pelosi after she leaves taiwan or when
she gets back here to get a readout or a
sense of that trip i don't have any
conversations that i'm that i'm
that i could announce or speak to um
obviously if he does have a conversation
like that i'm sure kareem would would
let you know
[Music]
when it comes to taiwan it appears the
retaliation has already begun
china banned exports from 100 taiwanese
brands are you concerned
that taiwan is going to end up paying
too steep a price for this u.s visit
there's no reason for that to happen
nancy
as we said today and yesterday no reason
for china to
take what is a
a perfectly legitimate and consistent
travel by uh the speaker of the house
and turn it into some pretext for amping
up the tensions uh or create some sort
of crisis or conflict there's just
simply no reason for that and because
she's not acting we're not acting in any
way inconsistent with the way we've been
acting now for decades since the taiwan
relations act was
was passed into law back in the late 70s
i can't speak for
chinese actions or chinese decisions one
way or another we're going to continue
to watch this and monitor this um i
would just say that
we don't support taiwan independence
we've said that before
we do support taiwan's self-defense in
keeping with the taiwan relations act
we're going to keep doing that um and
we're going to keep um
working on revitalizing our alliances
and partnerships in the region for a
free and an open indo-pacific and what
is this going to do
to the u.s china relationship which is
already so fraught
i think
the fact that the
president
talked to president xi last week for two
hours is an indication of
how
much the president
understands and respects the
consequential nature of this bilateral
relationship
as i've said before one of the most
consequential
not just in the region but in the world
the president wants to keep those lines
of communication open it is particularly
important to do that
when there's times of tension like right
now to make sure those lines of
communication remain open so i would say
to answer your question one we don't
want to see this
spiral into any kind of a crisis or
conflict
again we would say there's no reason to
number two we want to be able
to maintain those lines of communication
but a lot of this is going to depend
what the
answering your question is going to
depend a lot on how
china behaves uh over coming days and
weeks
hey john come back we'll come to the
background uh john given the the
concerns you were just talking about uh
in uh with china's actions in response
to this visit by the speaker
um the high intentions the risks of
provocations and the life does the
president believe that the speaker's
trip is a net benefit to u.s national
security interests or not
look we the president doesn't
typically comment on congressional
travel um as i said he respects her
decision to go um
and he believes it's perfectly
consistent
with american policy going back decades
and supported by both parties
but
he doesn't does he believe it hurts u.s
foreign policy interests in the region
the president
has already seen that speaker pelosi has
already accomplished
some important conversations on this
trip with respect to foreign policy with
her stop in singapore and kuala lumpur
and then you know she's
already announced she's moving on to
japan and south korea two of our treaty
allies in the pacific so um uh he
welcomes her
uh conversations she he welcomes her
contributions to uh american foreign
policy and our foreign policy objectives
overseas but i mean the trip is not even
over yet so
i think we ought to give the speaker a
chance to to talk about what she did
what she learned um and what she took
away from this trip when she gets back
and it's back to that that's why her
strike
does uh you mentioned that you weren't
going to telegraph the punches before
they were thrown but has the president
decided that the taliban should pay a
price or has he not decided that they
should pay a price for harper i'm not
going to get ahead of the president on
this i think the taliban already
has paid a price just in terms of
the now very public acknowledgement that
they were harboring zawahiri and his
family
and that the united states did exactly
what the president promised we would do
now beyond that i'm just not going to
get ahead of the president or any
decisions he might or might not make the
taliban have a choice now
but they always did but they certainly
have a new choice
and that is they can comply
with their agreement
under the doha
agreement comply with their commitments
on the doha agreement or they can choose
to keep going down
a different path and if they go down a
different path it's going to lead to
consequences not just from the united
states but from the international
community this is a
this is a group that says they they want
to govern
um that they want legitimacy that they
want financing that they want
international support
and if that's true then
one would hope that they would behave
in a manner consistent with those goals
harboring mr zawari and his family
and being willing to
to allow them to live in downtown kabul
and then
and then to try to cover up the fact
that they were
seems inconsistent with those goals
um i have a question on taiwan but first
on sawat yuri um was suraj shakani aware
that zawahiri was in kabul there were
senior members of the haqqani network
that were uh aware i'm not going to go
any further than that okay so you won't
say if sarajakhani himself was was aware
i'm not going to go any further
you've held up these strikes this strike
as a vindication of the us's over the
horizon
um capabilities but what makes you
confident that you can maintain that
capability and that this wasn't simply a
one-off i mean to my knowledge this is
the first and only counter-terrorism
strike the u.s has conducted since the
withdrawal from afghanistan it's the
first and only over-the-rising
counter-terrorism strike we conducted in
afghanistan
but you remember we also killed hajj
abdullah in syria using it over the
rising
so
what gives me confidence is um
the coming from a place of understanding
myself from previous assignments
what our capabilities are in the region
um and they're robust we said that at
the time we've heard secretary austin
say there's not a scrap of the earth
that the united states can't touch if we
if we need to and that's true and since
last year jeremy
we have worked hard
to try to improve those capabilities and
i'm not going to get into the details of
how we're doing that right now but we
have
we've worked hard to make them more
robust and the process of improvement
doesn't have a
it doesn't have a shelf life there's no
deadline on that you constantly try to
improve military capabilities and
particularly one uh in this realm uh so
i mean we can expect al qaeda is
probably going to behave a little
differently now so we're going to have
to be mindful of that so we're always
going to be working to get better at it
are you going to limit those efforts to
targeting only the highest of value
targets in afghanistan the president i
think
laid it out very clearly um back then
and then
and then yesterday that we're going to
make sure that afghanistan cannot become
a safe haven for terrorists who want to
attack or are plotting to attack
the united states of america and our
interests and then very quickly on
taiwan
what what is the us doing to prepare for
any further chinese action and
particularly any military repercussions
for taiwan uh from china are we seeing
any forced posture changes in the region
um and anything else that the us is
doing to help taiwan i think i
understand i'm not gonna talk about
forced posture or military movements one
way or the other um
yeah yeah nice try
uh no i'm not going to do that we
we take our security security
commitments in the region broadly very
very seriously we have robust military
capability uh obviously available
to meet those commitments we're going to
watch what happens here as closely as we
can the only thing that i will say
as i said at the the the top is that
we're going to make sure that speaker
pelosi's trip the whole trip
is safe and secure for her
thank you um
as you mentioned we're seeing some
pretty provocative stuff unfortunately
from china whether that's canceling food
exports or playing military exercises
i'm wondering given these developments
does the white house
believe that it would have been better
that
news of speaker pelosi's proposed trip
had not leaked last month would it have
been better if this remained secret
until she was on the ground look it's
hard to speak to leaks uh
in in this town and what effect they i
mean you're asking me to sort of go back
in time and um
and sort of just prove a negative here i
look
the leak was certainly unfortunate
uh wherever it came from it was
unfortunate uh because the speaker as we
have said karine has said and i have
said should be able to talk to her
travel in her own terms um
and uh and you know she when she she
landed she now she was there
one more very quickly
house republicans are already moving
forward with legislation they plan on
proposing it that would create a sort of
len lease program for taiwan is this
an overreaction is this something that
perhaps heightens tensions at a moment
when they should be
mellowed i won't speak to
congress and their motivations or
whoever and i'm certainly not going to
talk about proposed legislation i would
tell you that
it's time to wake up
i would tell you that
there's been
long-standing bipartisan support
since the late 70s for the taiwan
relations act both both sides of the
aisle and that remains today
and we take our obligations under that
act very seriously which
provides for a way a method
of assisting
uh taiwan with their self-defense and so
through the i can't you know i can't
speculate about where this proposed
legislation is going to go and i'm
certainly not going to
offer a administration policy statement
on it since it's simply proposed
but i can
be certain and it's important for
everybody to understand how seriously we
take our obligations under that taiwan
relations act and we're going to
continue to do that i mean even just
under
uh uh under president biden you know
we've uh we've provided a billion
dollars worth of uh defense articles uh
under the taiwan relations act so it's
it's a serious commitment thanks sir
thank you
thank you thank you john um sebastian um
so two questions please
um can you confirm chinese media reports
that the u.s ambassador in beijing was
summoned by the government and it was in
the middle of the night that's
the global times
uh we
we know that uh ambassador burns has
had discussions with his chinese
interlocutors um but i'd refer you to
the state department in terms of being
summoned in the middle of the night okay
and the other one
uh there was a um there was an
interesting uh nugget in the middle of a
latest thomas friedman column um
which was ostensibly all about taiwan
but he then mentions ukraine and there
was an intriguing couple paragraphs in
there where he's supposedly quoting
people from inside the administration
telling him that i can't remember the
exact words but it was essentially that
there's there's more there's less trust
in
zelinski than is being reported and that
there's uh
actually i've got it right here there is
deep mistrust between the white house
and president volody mizelinski i'm only
asking you because thomas friedman is
obviously
somebody who's read widely and
supposedly has you know contact with
people inside the white house so yeah
the president has spoken many many times
to
his admiration for president zielinski's
leadership and courage in this time of
war he has obviously spoken to president
zielinski personally many times
and
he knows the
understands
the stress that president zielinski and
all the ukrainian people are under and
that's why he has remained very
committed to continuing to support
ukraine
in their fight against russian
aggression
um he has uh privately and publicly uh
expressed that respect
uh for president zielinski and for the
challenges that he and his uh and his
fellow citizens are facing
[Music]
in an effort to advance the public's
understanding of what happened in the in
the insomaria operation
can you explain that the hellfire
missiles apparently have these blades
can can you explain how operationally
that worked and to avoid civilian
casualties what the capabilities those
missiles are and how it all played out
no
all right how about this one uh last
night um a senior official was asked
you know
to avoid
any doubt being aired about whether in
fact it was a warning it was targeted
there's multiple intelligence sources
multiple methods is there anything you
can
tell being heard about the fact that it
was in fact zawari who was killed
there's a limit to how much detail we
can provide on this um i would tell you
that
it's a combination of visual evidence
and evidence
collected through other means
that
led us to
the certainty
before
that this was
the guy
and
that led us to the conclusion after
with a high degree of confidence
that he was no more
is it physical evidence it's it's a
visual evidence
and uh and and
evidence collected through through other
means i really think that's about as far
as i can go
but the assessment is
high confidence
that
that we got who we were aiming for and i
think you know just without getting into
more detail i mean just the
the various things that
the people on the ground did afterward
also um
uh helped us come to that conclusion
yeah um
[Music]
well john kirby their national security
council coordinator with the difficulty
of course that there's no dna evidence
to prove that ayman al-zawahiri
al-qaeda's leader was indeed killed in
that attack that is what happens i guess
when you fire two hellfire missiles from
a drone uh into about a man on a balcony
in fact in a leafy residential
neighborhood in central kabul lots of
questions about what he was doing there
you know how come the taliban it seems
we're harboring them in violation of the
doha agreement that afghanistan would
not be a safe haven for terrorists
which is what allowed for the handover
of power which remember became very
chaotic um last august but there the
pictures then
no other deaths in that
high confidence that it was indeed ayman
al-zawahiri
and he said that he was the world's most
wanted terrorist he continued to be an
active threat although al-qaeda has
itself as he put it metastasized
fragmented into groups geographically
diverse still this was the world's most
wanted terrorist we will of course get
more reaction to that later speaking to
a former ambassador as well on that and
as you heard plenty of questions too
about the other big event which is nancy
pelosi speaker of the house of
representatives visit to taiwan defying
china and their threat of retaliation
will certainly come onto that as well a
little later in the programme
in the meantime the news that the mother
of twelve-year-old archie battersby has
told sky news that his life support will
be withdrawn tomorrow morning following
a decision by the supreme court today
archie has been in a coma since april
doctors say that he is brain dead and
continued life support is not in his
best interests hoshinki maruike is at
the royal london hospital in east london
and very very difficult times for his
family shinging